Monsieur B je suis présente la France a
plus 4 degrés 5 fois plus de vague de
chaleur plus 5 degrés en été plus de
pluie extrême objectif affiché sortir la
France du déni climatique mais c'est pas
la France qui est dans le déni c'est
vous et ça fait 6 ans que ça dure nous
nous avons entendu le GIEC quand il
disait qu'il nous restait 3 ans pour
agir mettez au France et le CNRS qui
s'alarmé parce que le dérèglement va
plus vite que prévu nous avons vu les
incendies la sécheresse empressant et
vous qu'avez-vous fait rien si pardon
vous avez des mains clés notre transport
ferroviaire rouvert une centrale à
charbon et fait construire un port
métallier même l'économiste Jean Pisani
ferry artisans du programme d'Emmanuel
Macron 2017 dit que le champion de la
Terre a perdu un temps fou qu'il faut
investir au moins 66 milliards par an
dans la transition écologique et imposer
les riches or depuis 6 ans vous vous
êtes acharné à toujours baisser la
fiscalité toujours au bénéfice des plus
riches et des actionnaires avec son
inaction et son obsession de la dette le
macronisme nous envoie dans le mur
climatique à toute vitesse allez-vous
créer un impôt sur les plus riches
allez-vous EMP massivement pour engager
la bifurcation écologique nous sommes
sans doute devant le plus grand défi qui
est connu l'humanité c'est de notre
survie que nous parlons vous n'avez rien
fait et tout s'emballe allez-vous enfin
instaurer le quoi qu'il en coûte
écologique votre fascination pour la
démocratie compte tenu de la manière
dont vous la pratiquez à la France
insoumise explique sans doute que vous
considériez qu'un plan ça se décrète
sans concertation ce que la première
ministre a commencé à annoncer c'est
quoi 100 milliards d'euros pour doubler
les investissements ferroviaires le
rapport Pisani ferries a été commandé
par cette majorité la refonte de ma
prime rénov la vote de la possibilité de
pouvoir recourir aux tiers financement
en matière de rénovation publique c'est
cette majorité le plan forêt le plan o
pendant tout ça non seulement vous
n'écoutez pas vous ne respectez ni les
Français par la démagogie que vous
véhiculez ni le débat par le fait que
vous vous réfugier dans des prêts à
penser l'inaction climatique c'est vous
depuis que ce gouvernement est en
responsabilité le rythme a baissé deux
fois plus vite les émissions étaient la
baisse des émissions a été tenue en 2019
en 2020 en 2021 en 2022 arrêtez de
mentir aux Français